Rishi sunat is the most inexperienced
parliamentarian to become Prime Minister
in decades and that is because his rise
has been astronomically Swift Just seven
years between entering the commons and
entering number 10 a far shorter period
than many of his predecessors just look
at the last uh three between 12 and 19
years they had to wait Gordon Brown had
to wait 24 years one man is missing from
this list that is of course at David
Cameron he waited for nine years before
becoming prime minister and one of those
who helped him and later Boris Johnson
prepare for their weekly parliamentary
joust was Michael Gove who he spotted at
7 26 this morning arriving at number 10
for a pmq's prep session later he
perched by the speaker's chair to watch
his latest student
take any lectures Mr Gove seemed to have
supplied Mr sunac with a series of Boris
Johnson's Greatest Hits attacking labor
on everything from Jeremy corbyn to
brexit
it's a
pizza coming from the person who tried
to overturn the biggest democratic
he was supporting the member for
Islington North the party opposite will
be backing The Lunatic protesting
friends I know the right honorable
gentleman rarely Leaves North London we
won't take any lectures on National
Security Mr Speaker kirstama zeroed in
on the reappointment of suela bravaman
as Home Secretary just six days after
she was sacked from that role for
sharing secret documents we can all see
what's happened here he's so weak he's
done a grubby deal trading National
Security because he was scared to lose
another leadership election there's a
new Tory at the top but I was always
with them party first country second the
PM said she had apologized for her
mistakes but dodged the question over
where the senior civil servants had
advised him not to give her the job
there was big news the ban on fracking
promised in the Tory Manifesto is
suddenly back so if
a man of his word will he stop
by reversing the green light she gave to
fracking I've already said I stand by
the manifesto on that Rishi sunax faced
barbs about his wealthy wife's tax
Arrangements I don't need to explain to
the Prime Minister how non-dom status
Works he already knows all about that
and his own wealth a nurse would have to
work over 20 000 years in order to match
the vast wealth of this prime minister
and notably in many of his answers he
used the c word compassion the values of
our compassionate compassionate
compassionate party while Mr sunac's
team will be delighted with his debut
the best joke was surely this from sakir
starmer
even his own side now he's not on the
side of working people that's why the
only time he ran in a competitive
election
the lettuce
I was watching from the Press gallery
and aside from after that gag the sheer
booming volume of the cheers from the
conservative benches was striking we've
not seen that for a long time certainly
today's head-to-head seem to force both
leaders to up their game